I'm professional athlete I'm worth
Champion Marathon I am a lead running
team got it home represents one of the
world's most exciting athletes this is
an athlete who won her first marathon
she's already world champion with almost
minimal scientific support this is a
hugely exciting opportunity because
science and Sport want to come along and
support what already is a truly
world-class athlete all
my trip and I work out every day so over
the coming months we'll be working
closely with god with Tom we'll be
bringing her to our laboratory in
Liverpool and will be conducting
physiological testing hoping to
understand the types of fuel that she
Burns at different Paces when she's
running we believe we can push her to
the next level through scientific
approaches to nutrition fueling
hydration and Recovery it's such an
exciting partnership for us
[Music]